I'm in Florida, by the beach, enjoying
some coffee, some sunrise, and some
incubation.
Joe Sugarman taught us sit down, hang
out, have a cup of coffee, write some
stuff down, which is exactly what I'm
doing. I got my journal,
peep the palm trees behind me, my Bible,
and some Clayton Makey. You can't even
get this anymore. Got this from Wendy
Makepeace, Clayton's uh wife before he
passed away. Uh she gave this to me a
couple days ago, so I'm enjoying that,
reading that. But enjoy some incubation.
Get out in the sun, write some ideas
down, go for a walk, chug some water,
okay, brother? Whatever it takes to get
your mind stirring. I hope you're having
a wonderful day.